finalizó la espera para las familias de
las dos mujeres de nacionalidades
española que estaban en campos de
detención al noreste de Siria donde
miles de familiares de yihadistas de la
autodenominado estado islámico
sobreviven desde la desaparición del
califato en 2019 incluidos cientos de
menores de edad por fin sus hijas y
nietos están en España tras años de
insistencia por las Naciones Unidas de
que las condiciones en estos campamentos
eran inhumanas el gobierno español ha
movido ficha un paso que llega cuatro
años tarde según el eurodiputado Javier
nart quien involucró a la Unión Europea
para que la repatriación se
materializara Paraná arte el gobierno
español ha actuado de manera indecente
al esgrimir que la repatriación de los
menores supondría un riesgo para la
seguridad de España
se produce un choque entre lo que es la
obligación moral y legal y la de
determinados expertos
cuya miseria moral repito es infinita
que entendían que la evacuación
significaba un riesgo O sea que niños
que en ese momento tenían uno dos años
tres cuatro años y que el mayor en ese
momento tenía 11 eran un riesgo para
España y en consecuencia que lo mejor
era cerrar los ojos y que siguieran en
ese guantánamo en esta conferencia de
prensa celebrada en las oficinas del
parlamento europeo de Madrid a mis
espaldas estaban el abogado de las
familias y tres de los familiares de las
nueve menores repatriados junto a sus
madres insistieron en lo difícil de este
proceso lleno de dolor ahora aseguran
que todo su tiempo lo dedicarán a su
familia de hecho solo una de las
familiares quiso hablar con France 24
tras la rueda de prensa la madre de Luna
Fernández una de las detenidas defiende
que su hija nunca quiso estar ahí mi
hija ha querido volver a España cuando
su marido ya estaba vivo todavía y sí la
han dejado cuatro años en un infierno y
ahora viene a España y me la condenan
porque por ilusa por llevar una jaima o
sea una helada por ser musulmana El
futuro es aún incierto para las dos
mujeres que ingresaron en prisión
provisional el miércoles por su parte
los menores se encuentran temporalmente
a cargo de los servicios sociales de la
comunidad de Madrid así como cuatro
menores huérfanos que vinieron
acompañando estas dos mujeres españolas